>> THREE LETTER WORD, WAR, IT
IS A BIG DEAL TO RUSSIA
DESCRIBES ITS INVASION OF
UKRAINE, THE KREMLIN HAS
INSISTED ON A MILITARY
OPERATION CALLING IT WAR IN
RUSSIA IS PUNISHABLE WHICH, ALL
TIME AND LISTEN TO PRESIDENT
PUTIN AT A PRESS CONFERENCE
CLOSELY.
>> OUR GOAL IS NOT TO SPEND THE
CONFLICT BUT ON THE CONTRARY TO
END THIS WAR WE HAVE BEEN AND
WILL CONTINUE TO STRIVE FOR
THIS.
>> BUT WHEN U.S. OFFICIAL
CAUTIONS NOT TO READ TOO MUCH
TO IT AS HE MEANT A SEVENTH
TIME IN WHAT WE WOULD FOR
CONFIRMATION THAT YOU CAN HEAR
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY IS BACK
HOME AFTER A VISIT TO THE
UNITED STATES, SAYING HE
ADDRESSED U.S. LAWMAKERS AND --
THE PATRIOT MISSILE SYSTEM.
HE LATER SAID THE MILITARY IS
--
>> THE VICTORY WILL BE OURS,
GLORY TO EVERY WORRY OF OURS,
GLORY TO EVERYONE WHO PROTECTS
OUR COUNTRY.
WE BRING TO UKRAINE TO BAKHMUT,
AND TO THE SOUTH DECISIONS
WHICH ARE DEFENSE, FORCES
AWAITED.
AND YOU CAN AND TROOPS ON THE
FRONT LINES AGREE WITH, THAT
SAYING THE MORE U.S. OPENS THEY
HAD THE SOONER THEY WILL WIN.
>> -- JILL DOUGHERTY
IS A CNN CONTRIBUTOR, AS WELL
AS A PROFESSOR AT GEORGETOWN
UNIVERSITY.
CNN'S FORMER MOSCOW BUREAU
CHIEF HAS BEEN DECADES
REPORTING ON AND FROM, RUSSIA
VILLE, IT IS GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> A, JOHN.
>> SO FOR MORE THAN 300, DAYS
THE KREMLIN HAS A CAR THE
INVASION OF UKRAINE AS A
SPECIAL MILITARY OPERATION,
ANYONE CALLING IT A WAR IN
RUSSIA FACES JAIL TIME, AND --
14 JUST THAT.
SO WAS THIS JUST A SLIP OF THE
TANG BY PUTIN, OR WAS --
>> YOU KNOW, I WAS REALLY, I
CAN TELL, YOU SHOCKED WHEN I
SAW THAT.
BECAUSE, PEOPLE ARE IN PRISON
BECAUSE OF USING THAT VERY WORD,
AND IT IS REALLY JUST SOMETHING
THAT COULD NEVER EVER HAPPEN,
AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
PRESIDENT PUTIN USES THE WORD
TWICE.
IN PUBLIC.
SO, WHAT DOES IT MEAN, I MEAN,
OKAY IF YOU --
OR, ANOTHER IDEA COULD BE THAT
THE RHETORIC COMING OUT OF THE
KREMLIN HAS CHANGED A BIT AND
NOW THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
AND OF AN OPERATION TO PASS
FAYE UKRAINE, AND NOW IT IS AN
EXISTENTIAL WAR IN THE WEST.
SO I THINK WHEN YOU GET TO THAT
POINT, IT FEELS A LITTLE BIT
COUNTERINTUITIVE TO JUST SAY,
WELL, IT IS STILL A SPECIAL
MILITARY OPERATION BUT WHO
KNOWS, --
PRESIDENT PUTIN WOULDN'T WE.
>> WELL, YES, IS DIFFICULT TO
GET TO THESE DAYS APPARENTLY.
HE USED THE WAR WARD, IN ONE
CONTEXT, AND AN END TO THE WAR
IN UKRAINE.
HERE'S MORE FROM THE RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT.
>> CONFLICT OF, THIS LEADERSHIP
OF UKRAINE FOR BETA I AND GO
SHE ATE, SOONER OR LATER OF,
COURSE ANY PARTIES IN THE STATE
OF CONFLICT WILL SIT DOWN AND
NEGOTIATE.
YOU SENIOR THIS REALIZATION
CLAIMS TO THOSE WHO OPPOSE,
THUS WE NEVER GIVE UP ON IT.
>> FOR THE RECORD, THE
UKRAINIANS --
ONGOING RUSSIAN OR CRIMES
INSIDE UKRAINE, BUT, IS THIS AN
OLD --
FROM PUTIN, OR A RUSSIAN SCHEME
THAT ZELENSKYY ACTUALLY --
THAT THEY WANT TO, BECAUSE IT
IS THOSE WHO HAVE UKRAINIANS --
>> EXACTLY, I DON'T THINK THAT
THIS IS REALLY ANYTHING NEW.
RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN SEEING THIS
REPORT A WHILE.
BUT THERE IS NO REAL ACTION IN
THIS.
AT LEAST ON THE WESTERN SIDE,
RUSSIA WAS KIND OF FREE AS A
CONFLICT MAKING IT DIFFICULT
FOR UKRAINE TO MOVE TO DO
ANYTHING TO CONTINUE THIS
OPERATION.
SO PUSHING BACK AGAINST --
AND HOPEFULLY SOMEHOW BRINGING
IT TO A CLOSE.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT THIS IS
REALLY MUCH, NO ONE IS BEHIND,
IT I DON'T THINK GRINNING AT
THIS POINT VERY MUCH.
>> PUTIN ALSO SAID THERE WOULD
BE NO LIMIT ON SPENDING FOR THE
MILITARY FOR THE WAR, AND THAT
MOVE WHICH SOME HAD SAID WILL
--
ELITES IN RUSSIA.
BASICALLY ONES WHO HAD ALL THE
DIFFERENCE PUTIN LAST MONTH
NEWSWEEK REPORTED RUSSIAN
ELITES IN SECRET TALKS TO GET
RID OF PUTIN, THE MONTH BEFORE
THAT FOREIGN POLICY CAN PUTIN
CALLED THE ELITES USED TO NEED
THE RUSSIAN PRESIDENT, NOW HE
NEEDS THEM.
LOOK AT THIS, RUSSIA LEADS ARE
STARTING TO LOOK AT THE
POSSIBILITY --
JUST A FEW YOU KNOW, INSTANCES
OF THE ELITE BEING REPORTED ON
IN THEIR ROLE.
SO WHO ARE THE ELITES?
AND WHY DID HOW SO MUCH
INFLUENCE?
>> YOU KNOW, IT IS WORD THAT IS
SPENDING, AROUND BUT NOT DEFINE
VERY MUCH.
ESSENTIALLY IF YOU LOOK AT
PEOPLE WHO REALLY UNDERSTAND
RUSSIA, AND THESE ARE RUSSIANS
WHO UNDERSTAND THEIR
GOVERNMENT.
I WOULD SAY THEY WOULD PROBABLY
PUT TWO AGAINST, ONE WOULD BE
THE TECHNOCRATS, PEOPLE WHO
KNOW HOW TO DO THINGS AND THE
HEAD OF THE CENTRAL BANK --
WHO IS A VERY ASTUTE PERSON WHO
IS REALLY PRETTY MUCH RESCUED
THE RUSSIAN ECONOMY BUT THOSE
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE VERY MUCH
INFLUENCE AT ALL RIGHT NOW.
SO THE PEOPLE WHO REALLY DO OR
THE --
HAND THAT WORD, IT MEANS POWER.
SO THESE ARE POWERED PEOPLE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
CHARGE OF THE MILITARY
INTELLIGENCE, AND OPERATIONS TO
SPIES, ET CETERA.
THE SECURITY SERVICES.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO REALLY
AS FAR AS WE KNOW HAD THE
GREATEST INFLUENCE ON VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
NOW THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
REASONS FOR THAT.
HE COMES FROM THAT WORLD, HE
WAS A KGB OFFICER, HE HEADED
THE KGB, SO HE COMES FROM THAT
WORLD, HE ALSO --
REMEMBER WHEN HE STARTED THIS
WAR, HE KEPT IT IN A VERY
CLOSELY CONTAINED GROUP OF
PEOPLE, WHO WERE ESSENTIALLY
THE MILITARY.
SOME OF THE MILITARY DID NOT
EVEN KNOW THIS WAR AGAINST
UKRAINE WAS GOING TO HAPPEN, SO
HIS GROUP OF PEOPLE NOW HAVE
ANY TYPE OF INFLUENCE MANY OF
THEM ARE AT LEAST AS HARD IF
NOT HARDER THAN VLADIMIR PUTIN
HIMSELF.
SO HE IS KIND OF IN THIS ECHO
CHAMBER FROM WHAT WE UNDERSTAND,
ECHO CHAMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
PARANOID ABOUT THE WEST, HAVE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, AND
BELIEVE THAT RUSSIA IS
SURROUNDED BY ENEMIES.
>> THAT EXPLAINS A LOT.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.